you probably know me
if you know me at all
as someone who does this
[Music]
there has come to us a young man aged
seven bearing the name
yo-yo ma
i've been playing the cello for over 60
years so i should be getting it right by
now however is that what i'm trying to
do am i trying to get it right or am i
trying to find something
this is not an ordinary master class i
really don't like to tell people things
so i hope you won't expect me to do that
but during our time together we're going
to talk about what creates magical
moments
that magic is something living and to me
that's the essence
of what i try to do in music
transmitting something so it lives in
somebody else
at one point i had the audacity to think
i could play a perfect concert
i was in the middle of a concert and i
realized everything's going perfectly
well
and i was bored out of my mind
that was the moment that i made a
fateful decision that i was actually
going to devote my life
to human expression
versus human
perfection
[Music]
music connects people you're sharing
something with others
you're almost like the scientist for
the inner soul
the whole act of life
is a balance of
unbelievably intricate forces of which
music
is a subset
i'm yo yo ma
and this
is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you